my wife was recording the internal  trainings that were going to be core to  building the infrastructure in our  company and after two days of recording  she sat down at the dinner table and she  was like babe i just don't feel like  they're like as good as they should be i  sat there and i was like do them again  she looked at me i was like what do you  expect everyone's going to judge you on  how good these are they might as well be  great and you just got a whole bunch of  practice and so she went back and  re-recorded all of them and they ended  up becoming the cornerstone of what  built the infrastructure that built the  companies that we have and so a lot of  times we think that what we put out is  good enough but there's that one extra  mile of effort that separates the people  who are good enough and just fizzle and  never get big to the ones that become  great and it's that extra mile that  makes all the difference